[Music]
thank you
so happy Thursday everybody Welcome to
the data science hangout hope everyone's
having a great week if we haven't met
before I'm Rachel Dempsey I lead our Pro
community at posit
Ive if this is your first time ever
joining us at a data science hangout
welcome this is our open space to chat
about data Science Leadership questions
you're facing and get getting to hear
about what's going on in the world of
data across many different Industries
and companies and so we're here every
Thursday
except for July at the same time same
place so if you're watching this
recording on YouTube later you can also
add these events to your own calendar
using the link below
but together we're all dedicated to
making this a welcoming environment for
everyone so we love to hear from
everybody no matter your level of
experience the area of work our industry
it is also totally okay to just listen
in and just hang out with here with us
there's also three ways you can jump in
and either ask questions or provide your
own perspective on certain topics too so
you can always jump in by raising your
hand on zoom and I'll keep an eye out
you can put questions in the zoom chat
and feel free to just put a little star
next to it if you want me to read it out
loud instead if you're maybe in a busy
coffee shop or something
and then third we also have a slido link
where you can ask questions anonymously
and I think Hannah or Curtis will share
that in the chat here in just a second
but I am so excited to have my colleague
Joe Chang joining us here today as our
featured leader so Joe is the CTO and
first employee at posit well back then
our studio
where he helped create the rstudio IDE
and shiny web framework along with
countless complementary tools and
packages
and Joe I love to get things kicked off
here by having you also introduce
yourself and just kind of share a little
bit about
your role and what it means to be CTO at
posit
yeah thanks for having me uh CTO is
actually an honorary title there are a
lot of different kinds of ctOS in the
industry and
um one of them is
basically a an engineer that joined very
early and it's a it's an honorary title
and that's what it uh certainly it
started out as for me
um started out as purely an
acknowledgment that
um their strategic conversations that
the that the board and the executive
team would like me to be part of
um but my day-to-day was still 100
software engineer and then uh Team lead
and these days I think probably 90 plus
percent of my time is as a team lead on
the shiny team
um it's a team of about 11 and I
um you know every once in a while will
do more CTO stuff which is
um having conversations that are more
sort of at the Strategic level with the
other execs to talk about um the
direction that we're taking the company
in so
um so for my day-to-day I try to do
you know 50 coding and 50
um leading the team that usually is more
like 15 coding and 85 percent leading
the team
um there's always emergencies and you
know last minute conversations that come
up so I do a lot of code reviews I do a
ton of
um sort of helping to decide feature
directions I do
um some talking with customers I do some
support
um just uh really anything that that
comes up and we try to run our team that
way for the most part
um most of our roles are relatively
loose and flexible so we really value
having everyone on the team
um or certainly all the software
Engineers to to be really thoughtful
about what kind of features would be
interesting to add to shiny to be able
to design their own features to
implement and and to be responsible for
the quality and support of their own
features so
um so yes for me it's it's shiny all the
time shiny day and nights
um shiny for R shiny for python packages
that complement shiny HTML widgets
for the last month I've been working on
a sort of the equivalent to the DT
package for R which is um a way to view
data tables data frames and data tables
very quickly with over which HTML
interface I've been working on that for
shiny for python where we have not had
that capability in the past so that
that's one particular feature that that
I've been working on but yeah for sure
the most of my time is in in meetings
and and helping other team other team
members achieve what they need to
thanks Joe and I I forgot to ask you
this but I usually ask everybody what's
something that you like to do outside of
work too
uh for me that's cycling
um I don't do it nearly as much as I'd
like to but um but that's my favorite uh
way to blow off some steam after after a
long day
I love it thank you
um okay so while we're waiting for some
questions to to come in from everybody
here thank you so much for for the intro
and I'm wondering if somebody had never
heard about shiny before
how would you describe it
yeah so
to me shiny is fundamentally about
letting data scientists create
Interactive
web applications
to uh to take their analysis that
they're
um already doing on their own machine
and taking the insights that they are
gaining from their data on their own
machine and being able to expose that to
usually other people sometimes to
themselves but usually to expose that to
other people in a really Dynamic and
interactive way
um in the in the past before shiny I
think you would see I mean it's still
very common to to issue a static report
and send it to someone and if there were
lots of variables in your analysis if
there were lots of different ways you
might want to slice and dice the data
you would either just add more and more
pages to that PDF or you know HTML page
and uh and we had a lot of people tell
us that they would exchange PDFs with
thousands of pages and good luck trying
to find the page that you want or you
would do this back and forth of like
okay here's my best guess at what you
want and then you'd have this endless
email back and forth of how about this
how about this how about this until they
find the needle in the haystack that
they're looking for
so that's just one example of when it
might be useful to take you know
insights that you can easily gain for
yourself on your own console in your own
notebook and to be able to turn that
into something that empowers other
people in your organization or that
you're collaborating with or just that
you think might find your data
interesting to be able to interact with
that data in a more Dynamic and modern
way
that's how it started that and teaching
statistics that was the other big thing
that we were sort of very focused on in
the beginning and
um boy it's been interesting what people
have taken uh shiny and used it for so
in terms of what it's for everything
from you know bi to you know machine
learning and large language models and
games and you know Fantasy Football
Draft analyzers all sorts of interesting
things people have done with it
um but one of the most important things
for us uh is that it is accessible for
anyone who calls themselves a data
scientist so you do need to code that is
very important to us that's one of the
core tenets of our company is that we
really believe in code first but you
don't have to be able to code in a web
development Technologies you don't need
to be a web developer to create shiny
apps you just need to be conversant in
the language of data science
thank you and I see an anonymous
question that came in a little bit ago
was which was what's the elevator pitch
and then maybe further discussion points
for investing in shining rather than
using point-and-click bi tools yeah
absolutely that's a that's a good
question and it's interesting this
I had one thing in mind when I created
shiny and then that has sort of evolved
as I've gotten feedback from people who
have you know spent a lot of time using
both bi tools and and shiny so uh so my
elevator pitch in the beginning was that
bi tools are great and you should use
shiny when those run out of steam in the
beginning that was really about Advanced
analytics so if you want to just draw
some Scatter Plots and line charts I
mean bi tools can do a lot I'm not
trying to be glib but if what you're
trying to do is completely within the
Wheelhouse of the eye tools great like
no problem those are awesome tools
um
and uh if you find yourself wanting to
use a predictive model that they don't
support and and you know there are a lot
that they don't support uh or you want
to pull from some data source that is
more Dynamic than a DI tool is designed
for uh then use shiny so it's sort of
like for the simple stuff sure use the
bi tool I mean if you can afford it a
lot of them uh you know aren't cheap uh
but then for the other stuff use shiny
and and I actually had a number of
people tell me that it was actually not
like that for them that in fact
um numerous times I've heard people have
to deploy to bi tools within their
organization or uh you know if they're
consultants and they're you know at a
client that the only deployment Target
they can feasibly use is say Tableau
they would actually build it in shiny
first and then Port it to Tableau and I
was like you're gonna have to explain to
me why you're doing that that is very
surprising and uh what they said to me
was that a number of the advantages of
just using code in the first place
um were just such big advantages that
they didn't want to give them up when
they were using Tableau
um so first of all it was very common
they would say for them to work really
hard and come up with this very
sophisticated Tableau application and
then
um or Tableau dashboard and then the
stakeholder would say oh that looks
great please just change this or that
thing and this or that thing because of
the way these point-and-click tools work
you would have to start the whole thing
over I mean you would have all the
insights you gained along the way but
the mechanics of building it you would
have to build it again from scratch
whereas for a shiny app you could just
you know replace a single line to you
know use a different data source and uh
or sometimes they would be like that's
great and we want the same dashboard now
for these you know 10 other departments
these 10 other scenarios and again you'd
be in this position of like the ReUse
was really a lot harder than than when
you're dealing with code so that was one
the second people uh told me was that
the extensibility was really frustrating
for them like to be to build
uh uh bi dashboard that serves you well
for a while but then to know that there
is always the possibility of some new
requirement arriving that they would not
be able to
um satisfy whereas shiny having a
ceiling that's you know essentially
um by comparison it's infinite
um was was very comforting to them
um and the third is that they the
feedback I received was that if you know
how to code that doing a shiny dashboard
in code is just more fun than you know
the point-and-click especially like when
you know what you want to do and you
know how you would code it uh it's
frustrating to try to figure out you
know how the point-and-click interface
wants you to express that
um and then finally uh just being
pragmatic people told me that
um it's it's like a better Resume
Builder to have built a bunch of shiny
apps than to have built a bunch of
Tableau putting click dashboards that it
led them to you know better career
opportunities I I'm just being real with
you guys
um you know that's not something like we
put on the website but but um I've heard
that too many times uh to think that
that's not a real motivation for uh for
some people
shiny because we're all control freaks
totally Luke
Joe a few people are were commenting
that was a very long elevator ride
[Laughter]
I tend to do that
was great though thank you so much
um Ethan I see you had asked a question
in the zoom chat do you want to jump in
here
yeah sure hi Joe
um I actually haven't tried
um shining python yet but just want to
get you some some high level thoughts
when you're developing Chinese food
python is there anything that you've
learned from developing it for offers
um and then you know it's sort of like
in terms of feature parity is it a asset
or liability for the engineering team
When developing Chinese for python
yeah very good questions
um
I'd say one of the biggest things we
learned
um
I'll say there's there's two main things
that uh come to mind when thinking about
the process of developing shiny for
python uh one well I'd say this isn't
something I learned but definitely some
other people on the team learned
um
jumping to python was not as scary as it
sounded
um I think for a lot of people that are
on my team are in JavaScript that mostly
are was the language that they learned
to program in and have invested many
many many years other lives and careers
and and
um there was a lot of assumption in the
beginning that like we are going to have
to hire a bunch of python experts
um and
like I don't want to be I don't want to
oversimplify because
um I think it is not true that you can
just like pick up a book and Learn
Python really well in just a few days
right like you you really need to spend
time with a language uh to learn Beyond
just the syntax learn like the true
pythonic way to do things and that takes
some time but when you're working full
time on a project with a bunch of team
members that are going through the same
thing it actually did not take very long
for our
um our devs to be quite productive in
Python so that was one thing is that on
a technical on the technical side
um it was not really a very difficult
transition for the team to to become
bilingual
um and I think the second thing is that
in Python this might not be that
interesting for data science but for
software engineering
um python in recent versions has gotten
better and better at uh static type
checking so the ability to to mark up
your variables and function arguments
with not only the name of a parameter
but the type that you expect it to be
and then having tools that'll
analyze your code and make sure that
that every function is being called in
an appropriate way those tools I think
are mostly seen these days as a
liability in data science that they slow
you down because you have to write this
extra code but when you are building
something like shiny it's a huge help
and that's one of the things that I
think coming away from uh you know
shipping the first versions of shiny for
python it's like it would have been
really nice if we could have these same
tools on the r side to help us maintain
shiny for r
sorry can you remind me what was the
second part of your question yeah it's
about feature parity like do you see
that as an asset or liability for your
engineering team yeah yeah so
um do you mean feature parity between R
and python in general or trying to
achieve future parity between shiny for
R and shiny for python shiny in specific
oh okay yeah so
um
I think it is it is definitely a
double-edged sword uh it's super helpful
to have built all this once before
because so many problems we not only
have a solution for but we have we
thought about multiple Solutions before
we decided on one and we can sort of go
back and and reanalyze very quickly uh
without having to invent you know too
much stuff from from Whole cloth
um but
the tough thing I think is that
sometimes we are a little bit
um
we try not to but we feel a little bit
stuck with the decisions that we've made
in the past so the biggest one that
we've been discussing to death
um not sorry we've been discussing
um
is shiny modules is a feature for shiny
for R where if you want to if you're if
your app is getting too complex there's
too much stuff going on in one server
function or one UI you can break it up
into modules and those modules can be
reused they can be they're name spaced
it really helps you reason about your
app as a collection of smaller pieces
in Python we have that feature as well
it's also called shiny modules well
python modules are a thing in Python and
the name modules
like for us to move away from that for
python it means now we have two there
are shiny modules for R and then there
are python components for shiny for
Python and that is super annoying for
all of us so I think there are a lot of
little things like this where we feel a
little bit beholden to the Past because
it would be awkward to have different
versions but at the same time it doesn't
necessarily always fit 100 it hasn't
been that bad but the times when it
comes up it is certainly is frustrating
thank you it's good perspective
Libby I see I had a question in the chat
do you want to jump in here
sure
um can you hear me my mic's been acting
up sounds good you can't okay
um my question is
if you could go back in time
to like 15 years ago 20 years ago and
tell yourself what you're doing right
now like what your career looks like
what your life looks like what do you
think would surprise your younger self
the most
uh
uh everything everything
um I I am
I've been unbelievably fortunate in not
only my career but in my in my family
life in my relationship with my extended
family I mean I I my life has
um yeah
yeah it's it's it's been an incredible
run and I think there were a set of
things that I really wanted to
accomplish by the end of my career and
um
I sort I don't know I sort of find
myself in my mid-40s
like needing to cast a new vision
because
um all the things that I wanted to do
I've just had the the great uh privilege
and been so fortunate as to have those
things uh sort of happen to me in my
career and I think in particular
um you know 15 years ago in my career I
felt like
I had stumbled into
this incredible industry just talking
about tech in general
um that that back then had a very
different feel you know like it felt
like we were
um it was not quite as mainstream and I
felt like I had stumbled into this
I mean so fun like such a fun way to
make a living to be writing programs all
day with smart and interesting people
and
um and to feel like I had
it's like all my natural talents aligned
with you know the skills and interests
you need to to be in software and the
thing that scared me 15 years ago was
um what if all of my career
contributions through Locker
happenstance add up to not very much
that was my fear was that you know I
have the education for this I have the
natural talent for this I have the
opportunity but there's so much luck
involved will I get the opportunity to
actually do something that is
interesting and meaningful
and
um
when when I was working on our studio I
was already feeling like oh wow this
could really be it and then shiny felt
like okay this is overdoing it a little
bit but I I mean it was like I never had
I never pictured myself coming up with
like a truly
I mean
I was going to say truly original idea I
mean the idea is like 99 building on the
sh you know shoulders of you know
reactive work that was done in
JavaScript but even like the insight to
apply it in this new way on the server
side to data science
um I never aspired to have an idea like
that I just I just aspired for somebody
else to have an idea and I would be able
to help and for it to be like really
impactful so
um in our little corner of the world
that is data science
um shiny has had a bigger impact than I
was ever hoping for out of my career so
I think that would be the most
comforting thing for me you know 15
years ago to find out it's not all going
to add up to nothing you know like there
is going to be some good that comes out
of the stuff that you do that um you
know that these ideas are going to
impact people's work and uh and impact
you know the design of of other packages
that are that have been created both in
iron and python so I'm I'm just super
super grateful uh for that because that
that was
like it was really something that I was
very very anxious about that that it
would all add up to nothing
so
wow this got a little bit real thank you
I don't think you have to worry anymore
about that concern you're good
thank you Joe and I I saw it and thank
you for the question Libby I see Lisa
said please answer this without making
us tear up again like you did that comp
and uh it was just reminding me like I I
love listening to you present Joe and
and how you tell stories and how you can
be vulnerable and put emotion into your
presentations and I was just wondering
how do you learn that
how how did you learn how to get up on
stage and make us feel all those
emotions that we all did at our studio
conference
uh you know
it's funny I can tell you exactly
um how it happened I mean I'd given a
lot of presentations before that one but
that was the first one that I was like
what if I made this like 90 about the
technology but 10 percent
you know share something that that cost
me a little bit
um
and
uh it was actually because I was um I I
attended local church
um and there's
there was this pastor who got up he and
his wife
and they in front of all these people
and being live streamed talked about how
he had cheated on her in the first year
of their marriage
and I mean it had been I don't know 20
30 years but still like that the two of
them would get up and talk about like
the most painful thing the most painful
betrayal that he ever inflicted on her
that they would both get up and talk
about it I was like holy crap like that
the courage that it takes
to do that and
I don't like I just got so much value
out of that because who shares that kind
of stuff
um in you know live in person uh so I'm
not trying to compare me saying oh I was
feeling a little bit bad about my career
to that I mean where but but I was
thinking like
this energy
is so
like it was so meaningful you know like
it was such a beautiful moment and there
was just no
like pure head Insight that could
compare
um and and I and I so it like it made me
feel close to them that they were
sharing something that was so uh close
to their
um you know
I don't know so vulnerable
um
so yeah I I brought it up with my
speaking coach and she was a little bit
like
wait why are you gonna do this and I was
like I don't know like I just really
love this community and I feel like you
know whenever we like the best parts of
this community are not it's not about
the technical exchange it's it's when we
do have those opportunities to get real
with each other like when people talk
about imposter Syndrome from The Stage
IT it those are some of the most
powerful moments and I felt like
like what if I did that from a keynote
because that story is true you know like
that
that was not something I had to conjure
up I think about that moment all the
time
um so yeah I thought
um oh and actually I have to give credit
to Jesse masterpack I told that story to
her
and she was like get out of town like as
soon as you said
like that was supposed to be my last day
at our studio I was I was like tell me
the rest of this story so she really she
I have to give her I think the most of
the credit for recognizing that that
story was one of those it could be one
of those moments
um so
well thank you Joe it it feels like
there's not really a natural transition
for me to go from this emotional
conversation to jumping back into
technical but we're just gonna do it so
thank you Joe
um I see that there are a few questions
earlier in the the chat I want to get to
um but Dan I see you you put a question
there about how you're starting to
develop in shiny coming from python do
you want to jump in here with that
um
yeah sure sure Rachel hi Joe
um I am a you know more of a python
developer although I started years and
years ago many Blue Moons ago with r and
really fell in love with it and kind of
coming back to it a little bit and
trying to develop the shiny one
frustration I have is just around
debugging
um and when you've got you know all
these pains and windows
um and UI widgets
can you share your thoughts around or
best practices tips whatever on the best
way to kind of go through the debugging
process
yeah absolutely
um and can you just clarify when you say
debugging you mean in a more General
sense not just using an interactive
debugger
yeah correct like I I do everything in
our studio at the moment yeah and you
know I run the app all of a sudden it it
just opens up and then closes uh or I
run something it spools an error and you
know it's not always obvious where the
error actually is it could be in the
output side it could be on the server
side
um and just maybe the pattern for
debugging and our shinies is so
different from what I'm used to it that
could be it too yeah it absolutely is
well especially if your work on python
was it around
you know like notebooks and scripts or
were you yeah you got it yeah do your
notebooks scripts that kind of thing
yeah absolutely so I I think for for
those of you who did not use shiny
especially
um when you were doing sort of normal
analysis uh with a notebook or a script
on your desktop your code generally
executes from beginning to end right
like you might have some functions but
those functions are called when you call
them and you have loops but they Loop
when you Loop
um it's very transparent like where
where The Interpreter is at any given
moment uh with shiny and and almost
every other form of interactive
framework
you provide code to the framework and
the framework decides when it executes
um so it makes it much more much less
intuitive to debug because like okay
this code is executing why is it
executing like how did it get here
um there's there's much
it's much less transparent
um when code is executing why it's
executing so there's a couple things
that I'll tell you from a uh from a
debugging perspective number one I think
that Hadley's book mastering shiny uh
has a chapter on this and we definitely
have at least a couple of video
resources where we've given talks about
this so I'd highly recommend those but I
have a couple of
um
sort of principles that that I always go
back to it as well uh number one and
maybe this less applies to you if you're
coming from python but
um stack traces are very important so
when you uh often when you get an error
in shiny you get a big bunch of lines
spit out at the console that say you
know from this file this function name
from this file this function name this
file this function name and and they
often are like multiple lines and often
people find that scary because a lot of
the function names that are in there are
function names that they might not
recognize because it's not code that
they wrote that's executing its code
that's inside of a package that's inside
of a package that's you know calling
base R you know exactly yeah yeah so so
it's very important to not be afraid of
that stack trace it is very important to
take the time to learn how to read those
and understand exactly what's going on
and what the stack Trace is telling you
is that at the moment that this error
occurred what were the functions in
order that had been called so if you
think about you know at any given moment
when code is executing for r
that code is probably in a function
and that function was called by another
function and that call was called by
another function and that called and so
on and so forth and it could be 20
levels deep that is called your call
stack
and uh when an error occurs one of the
most useful things to know is what was
the call stack and when that's printed
to the console now it's called a stack
Trace so you can take that stack trace
and you can read up it and just ignore
the lines that you don't recognize and
find the line that you do recognize that
says this was the line of code in your
app.r file it was line 49 that was the
thing that was executing when this error
happened and I think that you know for
the easy cases where let's say
I don't know you use the wrong function
name or the you know you indexed into a
data frame using an invalid uh variable
or something like that
um just understanding the stack Trace
that'll be that'll be enough for you to
fix the problem so that's one
the second thing you can do that's super
useful is uh especially in shiny never
forget that there is a JavaScript
console also that might be printing
errors and this is like
I feel really bad about this we should
do things in shiny to surface this more
prominently but when you're in your
browser looking at your shiny app if
things are not behaving the way you
expect and you don't see any errors in
the r console you can show the
JavaScript console in your browser and
if you see a bunch of Errors there
that's a big clue for you as well
often that means there's some kind of
bug in a component that you're using
whether it's in shiny or some kind of
third-party component but
um you know if you're raising a GitHub
issue or whatever that's like some of
the most useful information you can
provide the third and I'll and I'll move
on after this is to um so shiny does
demand that you write your code in a
certain way we have reactive outputs and
reactive expressions and you have to put
your code in a certain place to get it
to you know execute at the right time
that doesn't mean that your sort of data
science logic that your data analysis
your data manipulation and your
visualization that logic doesn't have to
live there you can write functions that
live off to the side they can even live
in a separate function they can even
live in a package if you want so you can
write functions that are not shiny
they're just our functions that perform
the tasks that you want and you call
them from shiny you call them from your
shiny outputs the advantage of doing it
this way is that if something goes wrong
you can test these pieces in isolation
from the console so you can make sure
that each of these functions that you
create that do your data manipulation
that do your data visualization you can
ensure that they are working correctly
and then your shiny app collapses to
just like a very small number of lines
of code and then it's much easier to
reason about you know when things are
being called and why
yeah that's helpful I I've been using
the breakpoints and browser and things
like that
um a little bit but it's still just
compared to what I'm used to
um a different mental model but I think
what you laid out is is helpful so thank
you yeah the the the
um browser and breakpoints are super
helpful when you need them but
um if you like on my team I'm constantly
using the phrase can you reason about it
I mean they must be so sick of me saying
that but like when you write code it is
not enough that it works if it's
important for it to be right it's not
enough that it works you have to be able
to reason about it and I find like
browser is the most helpful when you
have lost the ability to reason about
your code so definitely use it but also
think to yourself like
if this was really the only way for me
to figure out what was going on maybe
it's time to refactor my code a little
bit also
so oh great Libby said uh Libby harene
said I love tanho's little blurb
functions contain logic modules call
those functions at our cause and modules
that's great
yeah there's a lot of Great Links and
resources being shared in the chat too
um and just to remind everybody you can
save the chat too so those little
buttons below that say more you could
save those links there too
um Joe so another question oh Sam I see
you had a question in the chat earlier
do you want to jump in here
yeah sure yep
so I just had a question regarding the
various development Frameworks and what
your thoughts are of the development
Frameworks like Golem or Rhino for
production and great development has
posit considered releasing their own
framework Once Upon a Time so far maybe
they're released
uh yeah the question is that if you guys
are not familiar
um there are a couple of packages that
have been created
um
to sort of provide more opinionated
structure around how shiny apps are
written
so Golem and Rhino are probably the two
by far the two most popular
um
I had to say like
I'm a little embarrassed like this is a
very important topic and I know people
have like really strong opinions about
this and in particular I think allum has
huge
um proponents among people that I know
and respect uh I personally have not
spent that much time uh with these
Frameworks I think just the the
tradition that I come from in my
background in software engineering
um
uh
I feel like a lot of people
um sorry this is not the only reason
people use these Frameworks but I do
think that part of uh one thing that
I've noticed that people really like in
a lot of parts of data science is
especially if you didn't like set out to
become a programmer but accidentally
became a programmer I think a lot of
people feel like if they're doing what
it says in the tutorial if they're doing
what it says in an article that Hadley
wrote then they're doing it right and if
they're doing something that they sort
of invented or a pattern that they just
came up with then ah like that's a hack
or that's a workaround or whatever so
I've had a lot of people ask me things
you know like on the shiny issues or
shiny forums and say like Hey how do I
solve this problem uh or or it would be
great if you had this feature I solved
it this way but it would be nice to have
it for real and it's like
the way he did it is perfect like what
about this solution does not satisfy you
and they're like yeah well but I did it
so I would really like a grown-up to do
it you know
um and uh I think in the beginning it
felt like a lot of people were looking
for a lot more guidance for how to
structure their shiny abs and and Gollum
provided
um a set of opinions that people could
look to
um you know Vincent and Colin and say
those people are clearly experts if I
use Gollum then I'm like I'm like
allowed to do that whereas I had much
more of an attitude of like it's R so
you should feel free to package these
things however you want and you don't
need anybody to tell you that that's you
know okay or not I do totally reserve
the right to judge you but um but you
should do it anyway
um so
uh I think over the years though it has
like more and more people have told me
like this is it is it is not just about
that it's not just like a set of
opinions that are sort of nice to have
that they actually
um do try to provide like a
lower friction environment for you to do
development and or have been very
thoughtful about how you sort of run and
reload your app and um I totally believe
that it has value and I just I have to
admit I have underinvested in spending
time with those
um but I I certainly
um you know certainly I expect those
things to work well given how
um you know how much people use them
to go back to the question right before
this
um there was a follow-up question about
like could you say a little bit more
about what you mean by can you reason
about it
I think it might be helpful for us
though yeah
it's my favorite topic
um
yeah so
I think
um just to just to sort of reiterate
um when you write software or do an
analysis or whatever
there's a level of I got it to work
and then there's the level of like it
works and I can reason about it and what
that means is like software
complex pieces of software are among the
most
complicated thing
things that humankind has ever devised
you know like what other human-made
constructs can have you know hundreds of
millions of pieces and yet they're
expected to all fit and work together so
precisely that if one token is off you
know rockets explode and uh you know you
get the wrong answers
um
and I don't know what the limit is but
like you know even the smartest humans
there is some small number of variables
you can hold in your head there's a
small number of of operations that you
can hold in your head at any one time
um so
when we work on software that's
non-trivial when we when we work on
software that in in its totality is more
than the human mind more than any one
human mind can hold at any one given
time
um the main challenge in software
engineering is about how do you take all
this complexity and break it down into
smaller pieces Each of which you can
reason about
Each of which you can hold in your head
Each of which you can look at and be
like
yeah I can fully
uh I can fully ingest this entire
function definition I can read it you
know line by line and prove to myself
this is definitely correct if the
functions that it's calling don't have
bugs and if it's called in the right way
so with those caveats like if the things
that this thing is calling are correct
and I'm called correctly then the result
will be correct because the logic here
is correct
so software engineering at all but the
most beginner level
is a lot about this how do you break up
inherently complicated things that we're
trying to do into small pieces that are
individually easy to reason about
and that's half the battle right there
the other half of the battle is how do
we combine them in ways that can be
reliable and also easy to to reason
about so
um it's these two pieces small pieces
reliably composed if you can achieve
that that's what I'm talking about like
that's software that you can reason
about
so
um
there this has implications for data
science as well right like when you have
a data science
you're doing some kind of analysis on
some data and it starts out as oh I'm
just doing these simple things I'm like
doing this manipulation and then and
then I'm doing this visualization but
then as you get deeper and deeper into
it it grows and grows and grows and
grows and you're at the point where
you're at the end and you don't re you
don't remember where these variables
came from you don't remember like what's
the difference between this data frame
and this data frame and you go back and
um hopefully start breaking it into
functions or somehow dividing it into
smaller pieces that each focus on a
thing and then you join those pieces
together in your overall script so so
that is
um that's this principle of of small
small pieces individually uh
able to be reasoned about and when you
think about like other rules that you
might have heard about software
engineering like we know
um when you're writing functions using
Global variables is bad that's another
one of these things where that that
hurts your ability to hold the entire
function in your head and to prove that
it'll work correctly because who knows
who's setting that Global variable to
what value so you can't prove to
yourself like this function is
definitely correct
um
so um
I think
I like if there's anything that you're
working on that needs to be correct
um like if you're just like zipping off
some analysis and like it really doesn't
matter you just want a pretty picture or
something like that whatever I don't
know what that situation is but if you
don't care if the answer is right sure
but if you do care that the answer is
right I try never to stop when I have
an answer but I can't reason about the
code I always try to go back and do the
refactoring that's necessary just so I
can prove to myself that the answer is
right oh and the other big benefit to
this is that those individual pieces if
it does turn out that there's a mistake
somewhere you can individually debug
test unit tests those individual pieces
and um and when there are problems
you'll you'll much more easily be able
to find them
so
great thank you so I see
um an anonymous question that kind of
touches on what you've asked as well
Alan so I'm going to ask you to jump in
here too first with your question
uh yeah sure thanks
um hi Joe I I'm really curious about you
mentioned earlier that that you and the
team had to think a lot about and you
were sort of nervous about like how do
we learn python how do we learn what we
need to know here to do shiny uh for
python I'm really curious now that it's
like you're it's you're trying to gain
momentum with it trying to you know
establish it Etc like have you had to
come up with a different way to approach
the python Community than maybe you
would have taken for granted in our
community like we know that Community
has changed so much over 15 20 years
like what's it like to come into the
python Community now and and how did
that feel what what was successful was
it hard
um curious how you come into that space
uh it is one thousand percent different
it is completely and utterly different
and
I mean it's
it's hard to enumerate how many
differences that there are because there
are so many but the biggest by far is
that
um I mean python is just such a noisy
space well
that that's a really uncharitable word
it's a it's a very vibrant and uh Active
Space
um there I think in the early days of
our studio the company
um
there were there was a lot of interest
in activity around
are but
it was not like python is today I mean
python
it just you can't think of any Niche and
not find 15 packages that do that thing
and there are two more venture-backed
ones coming out next week I mean it's
just the level of activity is on such a
different level and it's it's quite
um it was quite a wake-up call to come
into that
um you know going to conferences and
things like that and realizing like okay
not only are we not a well-known entity
in the python World especially after we
uh rebranded the company
but
like the amount that you would have to
scream to get over this noise is just
incredible
um
so that was one big takeaway is that we
really don't have the luxury of being
hurt uh or taking for granted that we're
going to be heard with any particular
message that we have and that makes it
so much more important that when we tell
our story that we know exactly who we're
telling it to and that we know exactly
what's going to resonate with them
because I think in the r Community
um once when shiny came out people were
willing to spend the time to find out
like does does this really make sense
for me and they were willing to to do
some work and
um for python it's like
there's like 15 other options so like
why would you why and and there are so
many very I think because there's it's
such a big Community uh and there's so
much at least it's perceived that
there's so much money to be made being
content creators for this community or
whatever other reasons people have for
for doing content creation I've heard
that there is sort of like a Content
treadmill that people get on that adds
to the noise where it's like you know in
order for the algorithm to take me
seriously I have to create a new you
know python package shootout every you
know twice a week and you can only do so
much research you know in three days so
you end up with just this incredible
volume of like very shallow noise
um and that's just not something I ever
remember being a big part of the r
community and um and I know it's it's
for python users it's both a blessing
and a curse right like it's it's awesome
to know that whatever it is that you
want to solve somebody is out there uh
with either a free or paid solution for
you but now the work is figuring out
which makes sense
um and and a lot of the analysis out
there is is not going to be too helpful
um I will say though that in terms of
the the people that I've met in the
community there are like two really big
takeaways that I have number one that
almost everybody that I've met has been
very kind and generous to talk with us
and
um and you know pretty nice and
um I don't know like I had heard people
in the r Community say like you know I
have been in the python community and
boy it's so refreshing to be here and
whatever and
um at least the particular conferences
that I've been to
um and you know being 2022 2023 I don't
know how it was you know 10 years ago
but
um yeah I really
um I really saw a lot of the same things
that I like in the r Community happening
in the python Community uh maybe without
the sort of slightly more tight tightly
net feeling that comes from
um you know being a small community for
so many years
um
but the other thing is that it's such a
big community that I feel like it is
very very hard to generalize what people
like what a python data scientist even
is
um it is hard to even divide it into
four or five uh groups they're just
there's so much diversity there are
people who
are like so much more commercial than
the average our user is we're so much
more focused on like you know
this is a purely commercial sort of
interest for them to people who are so
much more extreme free software zealots
than I have ever met and that's coming
from someone who obviously like really
really believes in open source software
I had like a couple people ask us at Pi
data Seattle okay so like you have all
this open source stuff but you also have
like these complementary
um
you know commercial offerings
like to me you don't count as open
source it's like what are people who say
like uh because your governance model is
not open and you don't have like a
democratically elected board you're not
open source I'm like
like cool that you have that position
totally respect that but to say that
open source is the word that means the
thing that I like I'm like wow this is
not something that I have ever
encountered in the art world so again
the whole Spectrum has been represented
at each of the conferences I've been to
and I was I was I guess I was a little
bit surprised that it was not just like
such a big Community but so incredibly
incredibly incredibly diverse
awesome thank you I appreciate hearing
all of that so much really really uh
grateful for your your thoughts on that
thanks Joe thanks
Joe I I see there was an anonymous
question from actually towards the
beginning I want to make sure I get to
as well and it was
um I get questions from it and
Leadership about data security with
shiny apps what training or tools do you
recommend for testing our shiny apps for
example like pen test
yeah
that is a really good question
um I used to have good answers for this
because we would receive the pen test
reports from people
um and I will say
um
two things about those those pen tests I
think
um one I was surprised how well
those 10 test tools worked against shiny
in the sense that like the tools didn't
break like they did actually run their
tests and treat shiny as no different
than any other web app that they would
test
um so that was cool to see and there
were you know results that like once in
a blue moon would actually be relevant
um but on the other hand I think like in
my experience the the false positive
ratio to you know true security issue
um that ratio is like it's really
surprisingly noisy
um and like noisy in a scary way because
like they sound very very plausible like
these reports come back and they sound
very very plausible
um but like nine times out of ten
they're just using heuristics and don't
really understand uh like what the
parameters they are are looking at and
what value they have so I I would say if
your organization says to use them I
would expect whatever pen test whatever
web-based pen test Tool uh that you're
using to work
um but if you have red flags come up
expect to have to go through our support
um and and talk it through with them in
terms of actually improving your
security I think a higher value thing is
to read the um
there's the very standard I think o wasp
is the acronyms owasp
um the open web application security
project or something like that and they
have an Ever evolving list of like the
top 10 vulnerabilities classes of
vulnerabilities you need to worry about
uh when you're building your web
applications and I found those to be
consistently excellent advice like every
one of those vulnerabilities is one you
should at least be aware of and
if you're a more experienced shiny
developer hopefully you should be able
to
at least be able to connect the dots
between how they're expressing the
problem and how that might affect your
shiny app like
um you know code injection is one
example where you take a parameter from
a user and the classic one is you just
take whatever name they typed in and you
just like
glom that onto the end of a SQL query
string that you have right and for like
quotes around it
but that's that user that input is
coming from the user they could put
you know a single quote in there
input and that would finish your string
and now their input is being interpreted
as SQL code
uh so there's a famous XKCD about this
if you use Google for Bobby tables
you'll uh you'll find it
um so
uh that's an example of like a SQL
injection that's totally something that
if you weren't paying attention you
could introduce into a shiny app right
you you could form a SQL query that
you're about to send to you know oracle
or postgres and add user input to the
end so there are things that you need to
do to to not do that so uh for sure run
the run the pen test if your
organization does that but I think more
important read through the uh the oasp
um uh list of vulnerabilities
thank you Joe I see that we have gotten
to the top of the hour very quickly this
might be a record for how fast this time
it's going by
um but I see a lot of people saying
thank you so much Joe and Javier just
said shiny single-handedly changed the
trajectory of my career so thank you so
much it's so nice
um something I wanted to ask you before
we go is what's something that you're
most excited about as you think about
the year ahead
um
um I I
think there's a lot of things to be
excited about uh for posit the company
um
oh actually
okay I'm gonna I'm gonna start with my
team but it applies to the company as
well
um I'm really excited about some of the
people that we have added to the team
um over the last few months
and um I know like any time you hire
someone it it's
um at least for me I really feel like
that's a you never know how it's gonna
go and it can really
improve or
um or hurt the team and I'm I'm really
excited about the people that we've
added lately and and really excited to
see where where they help the entire
team move over the next year and I think
actually thinking about it that's that's
true for posit as well I think some of
um some of the people we've added over
the last year have the potential to be
um you know really the right people to
help us get to
um you know the next level as a company
so you have the people wow that's very
original but I'm excited about the
people
was there anything that you actually
wanted to ask us all here
I'm
um
I put you on the spot yeah yeah so I'm
in question answering mode I think if we
had more time yeah I I would love it and
and I I'll say I I have really enjoyed
um you know the times when I get to lurk
in these data science Hangouts I
certainly learn a lot from you all
um you know the the the discipline of
building uh you know the software that
we build is so so different from the the
using of it that you all do and uh and
we always want to be guided by uh by the
actual stuff that that everybody's out
there doing so
um yeah so I'm always happy to just lurk
and uh and hear what you all are up to
well we love that you join us here on
the Hangouts too and just want to say
thank you again Joe for for sharing your
experience and and Guidance with us all
here and thank you all for joining today
and all the great questions
I didn't want to forget to say again
that we will be on a bit of a break for
July but we'll be back on Thursday
August 3rd we were just chatting a
little bit in the zoom chat about maybe
having a little summer book club and
subtract is a book that just keeps
coming up I know Libby is really excited
about that book
um so I can post more about that in our
data science hangout LinkedIn group too
but if anybody is interested in enjoying
that joining that thank you all so much
for making the hangout what it is and
being here with us today have a great
few weeks and I'll see you in August